In this video we will create
a notebook table view controller
that displays all existing notebooks.
Sorted by name and
creation date in a table view.
First, let's create a new subclass
of CoreDataTableViewController.
Now, we need to implement a single
method, cellForRowAtIndexPath.
In this method, we need to find
out what notebook we need,
create a cell and display the
information of the notebook in the cell.
Only the first part seems new.
How can we figure out which is the
correct notebook from the index path?
And as fetch results is your friend
here, it has a method called object for
index path.
The rest of the code is per usual.
Let's implement it.
Now, it might be a good idea for
you to pause the video and
try writing this code on your own.
Feel free to press the pause button,
I'm not going anywhere.
Now, let's create
an NSFetchedResultsController in
view did load.
We will need three things here.
An initialized stack,
a fetched request and
finally, the NSFetchedResultsController.
Let's implement this.
Lastly, let's make sure we edit
this class to our storyboard.
Okay, great.
Now, finish implementing the code for
the NSFetchedResultsController
in view that load.
And at the class to the storyboard and
then take it for a spin.